Wilmington North Carolina is nearly
isolated from the rest of the state
because of Hurricane Florence most major
highways and roads in and out of that
coastal city of 120,000 people are
closed this morning in this video
interstate 40 looks like a river look at
that
submerged in Florence's floodwater so
it's an interstate more than 60% of
homes and businesses in the city are
still without power well david beg no is
in Wilmington where crews are working
nonstop to try and provide some relief
David I can only imagine good morning
Nora good morning they're getting ready
to hand out water and MREs to people
listen it's tough to find a grocery
store that's open around here not to
mention it's hard to find a gas station
that has fuel starting this morning
three different locations here in New
Hanover County are gonna hand out
bottled water and then they've got MREs
ready-to-eat meals
here's what's gonna happen at 10:00 a.m.
cars will pull up they'll give you an
MRE and water enough to last you for
about four days three different
locations around New Hanover County this
plan was in place before the hurricane
and they had to activate it but listen
it's been tough to get this stuff in
here at one point they were thinking we
should fly it in because the roads the
city is all but surrounded you can't
really get out of Wilmington or if
you've evacuated you sure as heck can't
get back in right now roads as I speak
the water is still rising roads are
still cut off and what happens is as the
high tide comes in the roads become even
more impassable as the high tide drops
and it becomes low tide then you might
be able to get through with a high water
vehicle again this morning the headline
in Wilmington food and water is being
handed out it starts at 10:00 a.m. it
finishes at 7:00 p.m. but Gail they'll
do it every way for every day from this
point forward 7 a.m. to 7 p.m. if you
need something to eat and you need water
they'll have it for you thank you we
could see with your little mini walking
tour I was wondering where you're going
but you showing that that there's tons
of water there waiting for people to
just pick it up but I don't know if you
could see that tape David I know you're
aware of it where you see the street
signs and how high the water is that
really gives you a graphic picture of
how bad it is there even five days later
still the water is rising alright David
we're glad you're there thank you very
much